leistet dann zum beispiel in meinem
beitrag über hashtag alles dichtmachen
wurde meine freie meinung in meinem
beitrag platt gemacht durch die auswahl
eines gesprächs gastes in ähnlicher form
gegen es meiner kollegin die ein halbes
jahr später einen beitrag machte über
hashtag alles auf den tisch sie musste
um schneiden sie wurde gezwungen zu
einem gesprächspartner zu fahren und
nach zu drehen die sind zu interviewen
der dann die aktion als kriminell
bezeichnet hat und mein zdf arbeitgebern
ein ehemaliger arbeitgeber hat es mir
sogar schriftlich gegeben dass das was
die vierte gewalt ausmacht nicht mehr
gefragt ist ich habe in meiner kündigung
in dem kündigungsschreiben schriftlich
bekommen zitat
redaktionssitzungen werden von innen
immer wieder für kritik am system
genutzt was bei kolleginnen erheblicher
stöhr gefühle auslöst und zitat das
vertrauensverhältnis ist durch ihr
verhalten so nachhaltig beschädigt dass
die beschäftigung nach ablauf des
honorars zeit vertrages für uns nicht
mehr vorstellbar ist wie lange waren sie
jetzt für den öffentlich rechtlichen
rundfunk tätig frau seibold ich habe 18
jahre lang gearbeitet also um genau zu
sein ich glaube 1999 wurde ich für die
heute ist nunmal gecastet da war ich
habe erst in meinen frühen zwanzigern
hat beschloss ich muss erst noch ein
studium zu ende machen und so richtig
los ging es dann eigentlich mit dem zdf
new york nach der journalistenschule da
habe der station heraus betrachten
gemacht und habe zum ersten mal news
produktion miterlebt
in ihr kann man das so halt sagen die
jahresproduktion das ist ja wirklich ein
sehr harter vorwurf wäre inwiefern also
der damalige korrespondent udo van
kampen bekam aus mainz die nachricht wir
haben hier eine meldung das war kurz auf
der rampe zum irak giftgas alarm in new
york alarmstufe orange und wir haben
dann recherchiert ob das wirklich der
fall ist in new york wir haben keine
belege gefunden aber mainz die zentrale
zdf brauchte einen beitrag für die
aktualität
sodann hat der konsument gesagt wird da
was leute wir brauchen den beitrag dann
sind wir in die korrespondenten wohnung
gefahren und der kameramann hat dann
also den heraus geklingelt nachbarn
gefilmt wie der also auf geheiß des
kochs modell mit die fenster rissen mit
im takt abgedichtet hat das könnte er
giftgas eintreten sodann nach dem biss
abgedreht waren wurde ich geschickt mit
einem kamerateam zu einem laden wo
gasmasken zu sehen waren mit dem auftrag
möglichst auch leute zu finden die sagen
ich habe panik vor einem giftgas alarm
natürlich habe ich keine leute gefunden
da war er gähnt leerer laden mit einem
schaufenster gruppe mit giftgas masken
die haben mit einem brav gedreht und
dann habe ich einen anruf bekommen von
der producerin wir haben jetzt also doch
einen laden gefunden wo man auch
menschen mit o-tönen bekommen hat die
sagen ja wir haben giftgas angst also
angst vor einem giftgasangriff in new
york und diese beiträge diese tolle
dieses filmer teil haben wir zusammen
geschnitten zu einem beitrag und er
wurde dann mitte februar 2003 vom zdf in
einer aktuellen sendung ausgestrahlt
findet man immer noch im archiv und sie
sind ja dann geblieben trotz dieser
produktion die sich schon wirklich sehr
skurril einheit aber wann hatten sie
denn jetzt in der krone zeit das gefühl
dass ihre kritik nicht mehr angenommen
wird oder sie wirklich auch gar keine
andere meinung haben sollten wir das
schreiben die kündigung ganz klar zeigt
also das ist ein schleichender prozess
gewesen sage ich mal es gab verschiedene
zwischenstufen aber es ist schon so dass
es immer schwieriger war bestimmte
themen anzusprechen fragen zu stellen
also ich sag mal das thema kinder in
corona zeit war eigentlich viel zu stark
unterbelichtet also da da gab es
irgendwie so eine art sperre ich habe
gesagt wir müssen wir jetzt mal endlich
zu gucken wie geht es denen eigentlich
wer als kultursendung als vierter im
fernsehen haben immer über sprache
reflektiert und ich habe zum beispiel
die frage gestellt was ist denn mit dem
begriff querdenker passiert also vor
corona wollte jeder gute chef mindestens
zwei querdenker im team haben und jetzt
ist es so ein tabu das man auf keinen
fall damit auch nur in verbindung
gebracht werden möchte wer hat es
erfunden war das nach hinten oder warum
übernehmen wir das so unreflektiert
diese diskussion war eigentlich nicht zu
führen also ich habe auch ganz oft
schweigen müssen weil ich wusste es
funktioniert nicht und wenn ich versucht
reinzugehen in die diskussionen und das
habe ich leider sehr oft gemacht dann
war es immer so dass ich schon wusste
als denkt die hälfte der redaktion es
kommt schon wieder und irgendwann
versagt doch einfach die sprache und es
ist ihnen auch wirklich nicht mehr
möglich gewesen neutrale beiträge oder
mit ihrer meinung erwachen also meine
meinung sagen durfte ich immer da gibt
es auch ganz viele aussagen von kollegen
aus anderen aktuellen redaktionen die
sagt na ja wir können schon sagen was
wir denken aber am ende heißt dann immer
danke für das kontroverse meinungsbild
was machen heute abend krone zahlen oder
bei uns setzen wir haben nicht zahlen
als kultursendung sondern wir machen
dann halt wieder das was sowieso gefragt
ist vps kann man denn den medien noch
glauben wenn sie das jetzt sie gerade zu
hören was empfinden sie dann wenn sie
das als bürgerin hören und ihr müsst ja
auch verstehen ich bin ein kind der aus
der ddr und natürlich die menschen die
aus der ddr kommen die waren immer
gegenüber der regierung und den mädchen
natürlich viel vorsichtiger eingestellt
als westliche länder dadurch habe ich
natürlich auch eine ganze portion
misstrauen von meinen eltern mitbekommen
logischerweise weil sie damals eben
unter der zeit der stasi sehr gelitten
haben und als schauspieler vor allem ist
es immer unsere aufgabe zumindestens in
einer schachpartie sämtliche sachen zu
hinterfragen und dann natürlich gibt es
bei der korona medienausstattung so
viele offene fragen die gar nicht
thematisiert oder diskutiert werden wo
man sich am ende denkt wo ist die logik
warum ist das so warum wird das nicht
erklärt warum gibt es dafür keine
offiziellen belege oder beweise zum
beispiel sagt lauterbach na ja wir haben
ohne diese maßnahmen mindestens 400 bis
500 todesopfer jeden tag zu verzeichnen
und er redet durch den maßnahmen leben
gibt es dafür irgendwelche statistischen
bilder oder analysen sieht man ich es
sind einfach zahlen die irgendwo in den
raum geschmissen werden ohne dass wir
uns darunter irgendwie etwas vorstellen
können ohne dass es da irgendwas
ersichtliches gibt um das ganze
nachzuvollziehen und mittlerweile ist
das meines erachtens vor allem auch in
der meinungsfreiheit so krass geworden
dass man sich selber schon die frage
stellen muss was darf ich überhaupt mir
nach erlaubten zu sagen ohne
gebrandmarkt zu werden ohne mein gesicht
zu verlieren und das geht wahrscheinlich
nicht nur die im zdf redakteuren so
sondern es ist in jedem bereich der fall
selbst im sportbereich muss man
mittlerweile verdammt aufpassen wie man
sich gegenüber dem pandemie maßnahmen et
cetera äußert und es heutzutage ist der
spruch ganz klug reden ist silber
schweigen ist gold paul du es ja karl
lauterbach oft interviewt auch hart
angegangen wie ich finde was hast du
denn gerade empfinde ich mein wenn frau
sei bei das so erzählt wie fandest du
denn die medienberichterstattung in
corona zeitalter ja vielleicht auch mit
blick auf der lauterbach
ja da kann ich jetzt in den details
natürlich wenig zu sagen wie sich das
ganze dort zugetragen hat ich glaube es
gibt bei den öffentlich-rechtlichen
genauso wie in allen anderen medien
solche und solche es gibt aus meiner
sicht tolle reporter und weniger gute
und ich glaube das ist etwas was jetzt
nicht speziell auf den öffentlich
rechtlichen
bereich zu münzen ist sozusagen was karl
lauterbach angeht sicherlich da gab es
am anfang eine berichterstattung glaube
ich sehr wohlwollend war ich selbst habe
ihn ja noch acht auch als ermöglichen
außenminister nein als
bundesgesundheitsminister genannt und
haben sich dafür ausgesprochen
insbesondere weil ich es absurd gefunden
hätte wenn die spd wenn sie denn dieses
ministerium bekommt sich nicht für karl
lauterbach aussprechen würde aber da
muss man sagen nicht nur bild sondern
auch andere medien die welt aber auch
die süddeutsche oder der spiegel gehen
durchaus mittlerweile kritisch mit herr
lauterbach oben deswegen finde ich dass
die vorurteile dass man sagt dass jetzt
diese ausschließlich positiv begleitet
würden die stimmen nicht aus meiner
sicht eine sache vielleicht noch zum
öffentlich rechtlichen rundfunk ich fand
es interessant um dann doch noch mal
kurz auf die ukraine zu kommen wie heute
eine kollegin bei twitter geschrieben
hat das
sieht man eine kollegin in berlin glaube
ich arbeite im hauptstadtbüro die gesagt
hat die menschen würden sich ja einmal
beklagen über den öffentlich-rechtlichen
rundfunkgebühren und dass die gebühren
nicht erhöhen könnte und dann sollte man
sich auch nicht wundern so sinngemäß
dass es keine sondersendung zur
gestrigen lage gegeben hat als gerade
mir putin angekündigt hat hier diese
sogenannten volksrepublik anzuerkennen
da ist dann eine große debatte
entstanden bei twitter
sieht man ja für 27 er hätte man das wir
bekommen und wie kann das sein also das
ist schon sehr absurd bei fast 9
milliarden gebührengelder das war ein
reporter sagen man sei damit nicht
imstande eine vernünftige
berichterstattung eine sondersendung zu
machen und das fällt mir ehrlich gesagt
auslandsreporter immer wieder auf ganz
unabhängig jetzt von privaten medien
aber dass zum beispiel wie sie die
berichterstattung
sehr sehr viel besser aufwendiger und
kompetenter und kompetenter macht
insbesondere aus dem ausland also da
muss ich mal ganz kurz rein gehen also
wir hatten einen sturm aufs kapital und
da ist das zdf einfach da sind einfach
furchtbare pleiten passiert das liegt
aber nicht daran wie viel geld zur
verfügung ist sondern das geld wird
einfach sehr zweifelhaft eingesetzt nur
kleine fussnote das zdf hat einen
eigenen angestellten der kunst kauft
also der hat einen bus nach mainz geholt
also so viel geld hat der
öffentlich-rechtliche rundfunk was viele
mitarbeiter gar nicht wissen es werden
momentan auch neubauten geplant auf dem
zdf gelände für 45 millionen einfach mal
so für einen nachhaltigen neubau plus
14,5 prozent teuerungsrate daneben wird
es studio n renoviert also davon wo die
heute und das heute schon mal gefahren
werden hat nach 13 jahren nach neuer
baum ein kaputtes undichtes dach also
man muss dann bis in die truman show
denken wo es dann schon rein tropft nach
13 jahren und man dann das ganze dach
runter nehmen muss damit es da noch
dicht ist und nicht irgendwie oben mal
so da tropfen raus geben falls ich finde
das einen wichtigen punkt den die
kollegen da gemacht hat der heute diese
diskussion ausgelöst hat denn für den
einzelnen mitarbeiter scheint es oft so
dass einfach nicht genügend geld da ist
also da ist der notar auf der
individuellen redaktionellen ebene immer
weniger geld für journalismus immer mehr
geld für zum beispiel neubauten in
österreich hat der frau bis ja auch eine
benchmark gesetzt also sich ein denkmal
in dem er dieses
multifunktionsgebäude dahin gesetzt hat
das war sein markenzeichen seine runde
marke fassbar dafür ist er bekannt
geworden beim orf und jetzt kommt der
neue muss man schauen was der macht aber
ich finde trotzdem
man muss jetzt mal ganz kritisch
hinschauen wie bei uns einbringen können
wie können wir als gewöhnen zahlung wir
sind ja alle so lange wir in deutschland
wohnen gebührenzahler auch in österreich
wir können weder überhaupt etwas ändern
und ich glaube da ist einfach guter rat
teuer wir brauchen konzepte an denen man
das festmachen kann dass wir auch wieder
eingreifen können weil das ist fakt ich
in der redaktion wir haben so viele
zuschauer zuschriften bekommen und das
ist dann immer so naja uns kann ja eh
keiner was also man schreibt eine
diplomatische antwort dies dann auch
ganz genee für uns ja und der andere
bekommt auch was aber dass man wirklich
darauf eingeht uns guckt was möchten
denn die menschen worauf haben sie auch
ein recht an berichterstattung das wird
viel zu wenig beachtet und natürlich
auch wo gehen die großen beträge hin
also definitiv sind neubauten aus meiner
sicht das falsche und in der tat wie die
kollegen schon richtig gesagt hat heute
es braucht mehr geld für guten
journalismus und für programm was vor
ort stattfindet wo wirklich die
journalistischen qualität noch wieder
zum tragen kommen das sehe ich momentan
ziemlich gefährdet herr gross wie es im
blick auf österreich wenn sie jetzt
hierher in fehlende meinungspluralität
beim öffentlich rechtlichen rundfunk das
geld wird für neubauten rausgehauen
dieses denn bei ihnen ist der york die
presselandschaft meine überraschung hält
sich darüber in grenzen dass wir es mit
dem öffentlich-rechtlichen mittlerweile
mit brainwash anstalten zu tun haben die
keinen information schon alles muss mehr
vertreten sondern nur meine meinung
journalismus also das was wir aus den
printjournalismus auf dem kommentar des
chefredakteurs kennen das übertragen
wird in die öffentlich-rechtliche
information ist nichts neues und als
keulen daten gelten dann die kanzel
culture mit denen unliebsame
auftretende gekillt werden in wahrheit
im übrigen gratuliere ihnen zu ihrem mut
ich hoffe für sie dass sie nicht wie
schon tag auf ihr einem scheiterhaufen
des öffentlich-rechtlichen landen wenn
sie hier auch so großzügig mit ihrer
information sind wie es denn tatsächlich
ausschaut also von herzen hut ab
verhindern und respekt wie sie das hier
anlegen das problem ist der
öffentlich-rechtliche hat auch keine
qualitätskontrolle mehr der
öffentlich-rechtliche kriegt egal ob er
schon produziert oder fake news
produziert aber meinungsjournalismus
vertritt oder vielleicht auch nur
objektive information immer die gleichen
gebühren egal ob die hälfte der gebühren
soll aber längst für diese show tv
geschaltet immer mehr als wir erleben ja
nichts anderes ich kann mir nicht
vorstellen dass steigerungs zahlen bei
den quoten für zdf ard oder bei orf geht
die ja man jedes jahr über sinkende
zuseher kassieren aber sehr wohl die
volle gage für ein programm in wahrheit
mit dem man ja nicht einmal mehr den
toten hund hinter dem ofen hervorlocken
und da bin ich jetzt wieder bei den
herren runzheimer dass ich schon ein
stück ich erkenne die dramatik in der
ukraine sich abspielt und wenn der
öffentlich-rechtliche zuerst eine
siebenstündige sitzung organisieren muss
ob sie denn vielleicht nicht einen sende
worden und dann kann uns darauf dass das
ende wollen aber nicht bedankt ist und
dann kommt dann als verantwortliche
darauf dass das ende wagen nicht
geschickt werden kann weil das kostet
14.000 euro wo man kauft dann abbildung
2 millionen euro oder man saniert die
büros der generaldirektoren ja dann wird
halt ein wenig problematisch mit dem
vertrauen der menschen sprich der
gebühren aber das ist viel einfacher
ehrlich gesagt also es geht einfach
darum was macht man aus dem was man hat
also zum stichwort bbc herbolzheimer
beim sturm aufs kapital da kam ich eben
vorher kurz darauf hat einfach der
bbc-reporter zusammen mit einem pbs ab
heute und einem tv-reporter als einziger
den schritt gewagt in dieses kapitel
reinzugehen live und das kann man wenn
man hände der tasche hat und du knopf im
ohr dann kann ich in youtube oder in was
auch immer live gehen und hat den
zuschauer mitnehmen in dieses gefüge und
der zdf korrespondent hat das gegenteil
davon gemacht der hat zwar natürlich wie
immer hat das zdf auch das recht auf
seiner seite versucht seitdem mannschaft
zu schützen die kameraleute und so
weiter aber danach gab es interne große
diskussion wie das eigentlich sein kann
dass da jemand einfach einpackt und das
dann wird zur gleichen zeit der claus
kleber twittert bitte jetzt alles cnn
einschalten wo er doch als anchor vom
zdf eigentlich derjenige sein sondern
sollte der mit seinem sender live
entweder selber geht oder hinweist auf
den korrespondenten vor ort der den mut
und die hitze hat sozusagen mit dem
schmalen equipment was zur verfügung
steht den zuschauern eine live
berichterstattung zu liefern und da gab
es intern in den öffentlich-rechtlichen
wirklich sozusagen krisenstäbe die sich
darüber wirklich ernsthafte gedanken
macht haben wie sie die aktualität bei
solchen spontanen einsätzen auf
vordermann bringen und diese information
ist was worauf der gebührenzahler meiner
meinung nach in recht hat dann er
bezahlt und wenn wir von unseren
intendanten immer wieder hören dass wir
ein modernes medienunternehmen sein was
er impliziert dass es eigentlich
privatwirtschaftlich ausgerichtet sein
soll dann muss man entweder auf gebühren
verzichten wenn das wirklich stimmt oder
andersherum wenn wir eine anstalt sind
mit gebührengeldern dann sollte doch der
einzelne der auch bezahlt in
mitspracherecht haben als wäre ein
aktionär